With each of these
projects, we'll
introduce the set
of questions that
motivate the work and
the key constituencies.
So here, what are the student
patterns of course choice
within the gov department?
How do they change for
subgroups of students?
What are the relationships
between courses?
What are the learning
objectives for each course?
And then, the key
constituencies,
undergraduate students
and the gov department.
Where do we want to be with
this project one year from now?
All FAS departments
actively using
a version of Enrollment
View, faculty discovering
their nearest neighbor.
And here, we get to another
curriculum mapping project--
Andrew Ho, who-- we'll talk
about this in a minute.
The Nearest Neighbor
Project has now
sort of integrated a little
bit with the Enrollment View
project.
And that's where we
hope these things go,
is we begin to think that the
synergies and the integrations.
And then the hope from
the particular point
of view of this project for
curriculum mapping at Harvard
broadly--
surface enrollment
patterns within departments
and across departments,
teaching your class
mindful of other classes
that your students are in.
And there's a
pretty picture here.
And I'm not going to talk
about the pretty picture,
because Dustin's going to talk
about the pretty picture now.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Erin, for
the introduction.
If I'm a jumpstarter, I hope
I'm on the positive side
of the lead.
So my name's Dustin Tingley.
I am a professor of government.
I'm also the faculty
director of VPAL research.
This is kind of a little bit of
an explanation of what we do.
And we have a really fortunate
role in the university--
to straddle the online space
and working with our partners
in Harvard X, but
also residential.
And that gives us
an opportunity to be
aware of a variety of different
approaches to education,
a variety of different
types of data
streams that come out
of those approaches,
and really trying to
leverage insights that
come from both sides.
How do we help Harvard
X with what we learn
from the residential space?
And how do we enhance the
residential space given
what we know from Harvard X?
I should say that this is
framed around VPAL research,
but in doing so, we definitely
work very closely with folks
over in HUIT who,
control a lot of the data
systems and whatnot.
They're a huge partner.
I'm just really glad to see
some folks from HUIT here today.
So what I'm going
to do, briefly,
is to just kind of
layout that Harvard
has this huge, rich array of
different sources of data that
touch on teaching and learning,
ranging from the student
information system,
the course catalog,
the Canvas Learning
Management System.
This is where you're
running a course,
you have a course website.
This is where you go
to find a syllabus
or engage in a discussion forum
or find readings, et cetera.
We have student evaluation data.
I'm not going to talk
about any of that,
but that's a really
rich source of data.
We have a whole range of
Harvard YouTube channels.
So these are official
Harvard YouTube channels,
and there's a lot of
great content on it.
We have Harvard X. And
then, we have a whole layer
of really just being mindful of
who should get access to what
data and what information.
I don't need to get access
to all of the information
that someone in institutional
research can get access to.
I don't need that.
And so we're very mindful of
thinking through authentication
and just sort of permissions.
And here, HarvardKey,
which has really
come online in a major way
in the past couple years,
has been really helpful
for a variety of projects.
So the student information
system, many of you
might think about this is
something like my.harvard.
And this is a place
where students go.
It's where they're going to
do different registration
operations, et cetera.
And this is kind of not just
an interface for students
and for faculty and
for staff, but it also
has a big data layer
behind it, right?
And that data layer
is very valuable.
I'll showcase a
couple of the ways
that we've been
thinking about it.
And it's not just some
projects that I've worked on.
But there's also
been other projects
that have benefited
from the nice work
that HUIT has put into
architecting the database back
end for my.harvard.
So one example of this
is the Enrollment View.
So this is literally just asking
a question of, what courses--
if someone has taken a
course in the gov department,
what were the other
courses that they took?
What sequence of
courses did they take?
Or, to get to Andrew
Ho's brilliant idea
about nearest neighbors,
if I'm teaching a course,
what are the other courses that
my students are enrolled in?
That's actually really
valuable information.
What are they experiencing as
they are going through what
I want them to experience?
And we'll talk a little bit
more about nearest neighbor
in a second.
And you can think
about these things.
So this is going to be for
the physics department,
so we've been working
with them, as well.
So I'm teaching a class.
There are these other classes
that students are enrolled in.
You can even see the second
order nearest neighbor.
This is like not your neighbor,
but the neighbor down street.
And what classes that
overlap are happening there?
Or what's the sequence of
classes that people are taking?
What have people
taken before my class,
and what do people statistically
tend to take afterwards?
And then, finally,
there's always
questions about, like, are
there trends in enrollment
that we sort of, within the
department, administratively
look at?
And so this is something
that we will be rolling out
to a whole range
of FAS departments,
working quite closely
with Harvard's
institutional research and
our friends over in HUIT
to be able to do.
Another project was just saying,
let's bring together easy ways
to just search
course descriptions.
And this was an effort that
arose out of our friends
in the Safra Center
for Ethics just wanting
to know where are
people teaching ethics.
And so we were able to,
again, work with folks at HUIT
to be able to import all of the
course description information
that we could get.
Also, grab some of
that information
for some of the other schools
that aren't on my.harvard
and put it in one place.
Make it searchable
and do all sorts of--
be able to make nice
plots of different things.
You know, a challenge of--
this is not really a challenge.
It's just sort of a
reality, is that we
are a little bit spread out
in terms of our data systems.
And that's OK.
That's changing.
This is a little bit of
a moving target, as well.
This is not sort
of fixed in stone.
It might change in the coming
months and year and whatnot,
but there are some different
data systems out there.
We have been working
a lot with sort
of the my.harvard
kind of back end,
but there are some
others out there.
And one of the
things that we do is
to try to think about kind
of common underlying things.
So that even if people have
different data systems,
we can bring that
data together and have
it be meaningful to be
co-located together.
A final piece that
really, I think,
highlights the opportunities
for merging data
from a whole variety
of systems, this
is the syllabus
exploration tool.
This is something that is now
available to anyone in FAS.
You can go to
syllabus.hmdc.harvard.edu,
and you can search across
most of the syllabi that
are used in the FAS.
So how do we do that?
So what's one thing that
you're supposed to do,
if you're an instructor,
on your Canvas site?
What's one thing that
you're supposed to do?
What should you do?
You should post your syllabus.
Now, you're going to do that
in a variety of different ways,
because I can see that data.
There are particular ways
we prefer you to do it,
but whatever.
We'll figure it out.
And so what we did is we--
working very closely
with Dean Mike Smith--
went out and got
syllabi from across all
of these different courses.
Took those files, extracted
the text from them,
and then essentially
made it searchable.
So you can go in, and you
can find people's syllabi
and actually get the actual
file that was their syllabus.
And think of these syllabi
as being, essentially,
like a curated reading list.
So if you're writing
a senior thesis
and you're interested
in some topic,
well, one thing you could do is
you could go to Google and type
in that topic.
And then who knows where
you're going, right?
But why not, if you
could, in a sense,
Google the inside of some of the
most brilliant people's minds
in the world and see what
they would suggest reading,
given your topic, that would
be a much greater opportunity.
So the syllabus project
took information
from Canvas, the learning
management system,
on the one hand,
brought it together
with some other information from
the operational data storage
system in HUIT, and put
those things together.
And now we have this
as a product for FAS.
And furthermore, it's
been written in a way
that we hope some of our
friends from other schools
would be interested
in joining the party.
So at some point, this
could be something
like syllabus.harvard.edu
and really scale
across the institution.
That's a dream right now,
but I'm a jumpstarter,
so I'll leave it there.